I wanted to actually start uh with a challenge,
a little puzzle. People are probably familiar
with the tetrahedron, and here's a square based
pyramid, so the triangular faces are both the same
on these shapes. The challenge for you, and we'll
perhaps solve it at the end of the video, is if I
put these two shapes together tell me how many
faces there are on the shape that I would make
by fusing two of the triangular faces together.
Okay, there's your challenge. You might think, oh,
it doesn't sound terribly difficult for us
Numberphile- so but we'll look at that at
the end. What I wanted to talk about in this video
was an interesting thing I discovered working with
a sculptor that lives nearby my house here;
he's very famous actually, Conrad Shawross,
and he loves using mathematical shapes in the
sculptures that he makes. And one of the early
challenges he faced, he realised that using a bit
of mathematics actually cut down the amount of
work that he had to do as a sculptor. So he's been
really obsessed with this shape the tetrahedron;
he sort of thought this was like one of the
great building blocks of nature, and indeed
he's right. The ancient Greeks of course thought
the platonic solids were the kind of atoms that
made up the universe. So at that time we thought
earth, wind, fire and water were the atoms of
the universe; and each of those would have a
shape. Earth, that was the shape of the cube;
water, the icosahedron, made out of 20 equilateral
triangles; air was the octahedron made out of
eight equilateral triangles; and fire was this
shape here, the tetrahedron, the kind of spikiest
of the shapes. Of course we've got one platonic
solid left over which is the dodecahedron,
and Plato left that to be the shape of the
universe, which is kind of interesting.
But Conrad Shawcross was- was interested
as a sculptor in, yeah, well what about
taking this atomic shape the tetrahedron and and
seeing what he can build out of it. So one of his
very first projects, he built 2,000 tetrahedrons
and set himself the task of trying to see
what he could build out of these tetrahedrons.
And actually he had a deadline and suddenly the
deadline looms and he's got to try and find how
to put these 2,000 tetrahedron together; but then
he talked to a mathematician who said, well you
realise you don't actually have 2,000 objects
you've got to find how to put them together? In
fact you have a much smaller number of building
blocks. Because if you put two tetrahedron
together for example there's really only
one shape you can make out of that, there isn't
another way I can put these tetrahedron together
and get a different sort of shape. So
already actually you've halved the problem;
and and this is the power of symmetry, you
know, and that's my area of expertise, symmetry.
Symmetry often is a clever way of cutting down a
problem which at first sight seems like there are,
you know, 2,000 different things you've got to
put together. But then he realised, no actually,
you can halve that. There are only 1,000 objects
that you need to consider, I've just got to put
these together. But the mathematician said, no
in fact you can cut it down even more because
if I have three tetrahedron there's only one
way I can put three tetrahedron together.
So here are my little paper tetrahedron I made
earlier for you. Here's our two put together;
but actually there's only one way I can attach
a third object, and what I make is this kind of
weird shape almost little like a boat isn't it?
So you might say, okay well that's one way to
put the tetrahedron together but maybe I can
fuse this on a different edge - and look I've
got something different. But of course the point
is that symmetry means that I can turn this and
I've always got that little boat structure. So it
doesn't matter how many different ways I try, the
symmetry means I'll always get the same object.
So Conrad used this as a shortcut in a way,
the symmetry of how you put these together,
to say I don't need to consider 2,000 I
only need to consider a third of that and
use this as my basic building block; and
that's what he used to make some of his uh first
interesting structuresout of this tetrahedron.
(Brady: But if you go up to fourthen it-
then you lose it? Four you canstart-)
Yeah then you start to um have uh different
directions that you're coming out, and so this is
really the basic building block for his sculptures
is this particular one here - but then there are
new decisions you've got to make. And what
he found was there were interesting tendrils;
quite unexpected shapes that emerged out
of this. If you look at Conrad's work
you see just amazing kind of weird directions that
he's been taken on by this particular object. And
recently he's discovered a kind of new sort of
shape which I actually had not been aware of;
because one of the interesting thing is with
platonic solids, which of them can you pack
and fill space with? A cube? Clearly you can
stack cubes and and fill the whole of space, but
do any of the other objects actually fill
space? You can take a a slightly non-symmetrical
tetrahedron, squash it a bit and fill space with
that. But with the actual symmetrical tetrahedron,
if you try and fill space it doesn't work, and
there's always kind of a little bit left over.
And Conrad's made this very interesting
shape that looks like it's trying to be a
an icosahedron, it's sort of building up lots
of triangles, but they don't quite fit together
and there's kind of an interesting gap. I
think that's very interesting, an artist
using these shapes to sort of discover verya
asymmetrical shape made out of these tetrahedrons.
It looks like it's trying to be something
symmetrical but doesn't quite work, it's kind of
interesting, the sweet spot between something that
is trying to be perfect but it isn't quite. (Does
that tetrahedral boat have a name?) - It really
should do doesn't it? I mean- but now you've
challenged me with that I don't know what that
would be called - perhaps people in the comments
down below, either we can christen it, give it a
name, or maybe somebody does knowa name for that.
Perhaps it could be called theShawcross shape
or something.
- (It is boat-y.)
It is a little bit boat-y.
So I think it's interesting
how you can use symmetry very often to to
cut down the hard work you've got to do;
and and very often in when I'm looking
at a particular mathematical problem,
sometimes you're looking at an equation um
and it can be solved in many different ways,
uh but spotting that actually all of the solutions
are kind of symmetrical versions of each other
is often a way of cutting down the work. You
just have to find one solution and then use the
symmetry to find all of the others. So that's a
very common trick in mathematics and in science.
But it was intriguing, it was the first time
I'd seen it used by a sculptor as a- you know,
oh yeah use the symmetry and cut down the work.
- (What work washe cutting down Professor?
Was it- was it- was)
(he having to cast less pieces
or something likethat?)
- Well he'd actually made all of these 2,000
cubes out of wood; but what he'd cut down was
just- what he needed to put together was these
three and then they were the building blocks
from which everything else- you know, there was
nothing new that would emerge if he hadn't have
done that. At first I think there may be many more
possibilities but the symmetry showed, no, all of
these are actually examples of the same thing. So
maybe we should come back to our little challenge
because that was about putting shapes together and
understanding what shape emerges by putting two
together. So at first sight you may say this is
pretty obvious - this shape has 5 faces, this one
has 4 faces, when I put these together I lose two
faces. So 5 plus 4 is 9, so I should get 7 faces.
So what's the big uh problem? But
something rather curious happens
because when I put these together I lose two
more faces! Because look at this - these two
line up, and so these two actually become one
face, so this object actually has 5 faces: 1, 2,
3, 4, 5 faces.
So that's a little bit
of a surprise that comes out of that. I hope you
perhaps experienced an 'oh, that's unexpected'.
And what's curious about this is this was set in
one of the SAT exams uh in America, just to see
how good you are at conceptual visualisation. And
they didn't realise that um- this kind of rather
curious answer. So the the people who said 7
got the score and those who said 5 um were given
no marks at all, but actually it turns out
rather curiously that when you put these together
um this shape actually only has 5 faces. In
this shape you've got um 2 faces on this side
and 2 that faces on this side that fuse. So so
actually this - which you might have first thought
counted as uh 2 different faces - you've
got 1, 2, 3, the square on the bottom,
and the last triangle there, 5.
- (Totally got me.)
Iknow!
- (I would
have got the mark in theSATs though.)
- Exactly! That was what was so crazy.
See the links in the description for
more videoswith Marcus du Sautoy
plus links to his books and theatre productions
- other things he's up to. ...so for example
you might want to know - well is this
particular statement provable from the axioms?